hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
welcome to this week's winners on a
wednesday winners on a wednesday is
really an opportunity for you to see
real life testimonies and case studies
of people that are succeeding in
property
it's also a really good opportunity for
me to be inspired as well because i
often get messages on instagram and on
facebook for people saying
samuel i came to your crash course i did
some online training with you
and i'm doing really well in property
you've changed my life and i'm always
really
pleased to read the messages but if i
only read the messages i wouldn't
believe it unless i saw some people in
real life
that's why i have people come and sit in
my living room so this guy i'm about to
introduce you to
claudio he has got 10 properties they're
all in his
name he's bought them all himself he's
got five in the uk but then he's then
done the same thing in his home country
in italy
so claudio great to have you on the show
thank you very much for having me
samuel you've done you've done so well
and you've you're a regular
you're a regular attendee of the crash
course 100
yeah i attended uh twice uh actually
three times the uh the crash course
what happened the third time you arrived
late and you were sent home i arrived
late and i was sent back yeah
i don't believe that that's really what
happened maybe you were talking about
the truth
yeah but but you know what the claudio
uh in all seriousness i'm really really
happy to have you here it's great to see
people
uh not only implement the training on
the property side but you've also you're
also killing
on on your business what tell me about
your business
yeah so um i am uh working as a
consultant in the software space so um
basically make websites and we help
clients
uh with their with their websites and
with their web apps and
um on the side we also have an
investment i have an investment uh
business to do with property so yeah
mainly buy to let we will get into that
but with ten houses
yeah it's it's now in the double digits
so
so so good well firstly i just want to
say how happy it makes me feel just to
see people winning
that i always want to be around people
that are winning so talk to me claudio
why did you choose property and how did
you initially get into the
whole world of property investing i
think i was looking for ways to
uh get out of the rat race you know and
uh
i resonated with a lot of the content
that you put out on
on youtube i think first and foremost
and then after youtube i
bought your books i started with buy low
rent high
and uh that was you know it kind of
given it gave me a different mindset but
at the same time the clear steps
that i needed in order for me to be able
to when was this when did you take
my when did you first read my book it
was 2018.
okay 2018 for sure yeah a couple years
ago a couple years ago and a lot has
changed since then
yeah at this point when you first read
barlow rent high yeah did you have any
property experience did you own any
properties did you have any investments
no zero so this was literally for you a
whole new territory
a whole new territory um i had um
the the will to succeed but i didn't
have the uh the knowledge necessarily
and and not even the right mindset
obviously
these are things that you work on uh
gradually and and uh you know your books
and your content has been uh
kind of pivotal and interesting that you
said to me off camera you said that the
the training has not only helped you
with your investments of choosing the
right properties and
and that whole side of thing but it's
also helped you in your business
talk to me a little bit about that yeah
absolutely it's it's um
a lot to do with property and having the
right knowledge but also to do with
mindset
and uh otherwise people you know i
wouldn't have had the courage
to send you know 50 or 60 grand to a
faceless um
group of people uh the uh you know a
legal team
yeah to buy my first property like it
takes a little bit of courage
and in order for for that to to
in order for you to have that courage
you have to go through
uh a little bit of um of uh
of you need to do work on yourself and i
get that yeah i get that
there's a saying i think you might have
heard me says before where i say
four frogs were on a log one decided to
jump off
how many were left on and the answer is
four because one decided to jump off but
they didn't actually jump and i think
in the same way i see so many people who
even even if they've read the books
they've watched the youtube videos
they've got a little bit of knowledge
but
if you haven't got that umph to actually
jump
then you're not going to succeed and the
thing that you've done so successfully
over the last couple years which i'm
really
pleased to see is with your business
with your properties
you've jumped you've taken a massive
massive action
and that's that's super impressive so go
on
yeah no sorry it just came to mind that
the one of the things that
i think differentiates your content from
other people's content
is the fact that you lay down the steps
uh to such a fine detail that
it's easy for even for someone like me
that at the time had no experience
to get that confidence and i think
confidence comes from very different
things but
one of the things that it comes from at
least for me
is having the exact number of steps the
exact steps knowing
knowing exactly what it is that you
should be you should be doing so it was
easier
it's so true because if you've got the
knowledge confidence does come
and some people probably shouldn't be
confident because if they
don't know what they're doing exactly
exactly talk me through your first deal
then
how did you find it where was it and
talk me through
how much you paid for it what the rent
is what the yield is we're really
curious
yes so um it started with me being a
little bit of a copycat at that point
because i had no experience no knowledge
but i have a lot of will to to change my
situation financially
first and foremost so um watching your
content
i understood about uh well the basics of
property how it works and also
uh the yields you know uh it doesn't
make sense to buy
let's say a property in uh in london if
what you want to do is
um then renting it as a single let
because there's areas where
uh yields are very different so you may
be able to get a better deal
easier in a different location so it
doesn't have to be the same location
that you
you were born in and that's something
that utah
taught me um so i picked uh i picked
stoke on trent because it kind of ticked
a lot of the
a lot of the requirements that are
important for for a property investment
and i picked as a strategy the buy to
let strategy because
the way i understand property um
the buy to let strategy doesn't have
a lot of risk involved and it's fairly
simple at least i
understand it i can make sense of it so
i thought let's start with that
and so i picked stoke on trent i think
stoke and trent
is a place that you mentioned in one of
one of the videos that i watched
uh as well and uh i got to meet some
some great people a very um very nice
property manager uh they uh sourced the
deal for me
and then i took a look at a few deals i
went around
doing the viewings doing all my due
diligence and and everything that i
learned in the in the crash course
uh most things i did probably wrong but
some things i did right
and uh i ended up with this uh deal um
in stoke and trent uh uh terraced house
uh fairly inexpensive but with a with a
with a good rent
i think uh yeah over 400
and then um yeah the property manager
would charge me 10
a month for them to kind of uh deal with
uh
finding tenants and and organizing
everything and i would just
get paid every month and how much how
much do you pay for that property so
that property cost
i think uh 54 000 i paid 54 000. was
that obviously
was it in good condition when you bought
it it was in good condition and you had
tenants already in there
right so you're here you're you're the
ultimate example of a passive investor
right
yes yes you're focused on your business
your business is doing well you're
making good profits you're the director
which is awesome
you're then using that money and you're
strategically investing it to try and
give you passive income
yes which is why you've got a management
team in place you've bought it with
tenants you've got it in good condition
yes so 54 000 pounds giving you 400
pound a month rent
that's a pretty decent yield yes and and
it's a lot lot better than investing
that money into something that's not
bricks and mortar i mean why did you
choose
property because there's lots of
different things you can invest in you
could buy gold
silver why bitcoin you use property
i think uh it comes down to uh to me the
way i
understand investments uh it's all like
a spectrum of risk
and it goes from literally not investing
keeping all the money in the bank
holding money uh
and uh all the most um extravagant and
um
aggressive ways of investing such as you
know it could be
cryptocurrency or anything that requires
a lot of
specialized knowledge in that i don't
necessarily have
and a lot of time and work if you invest
in a business for example or if you buy
a business or if you start a new
business
but in my case i was looking for
something somewhere in the middle so i
think that property was
on one hand very safe because
it's brick and mortar it doesn't go
anywhere um
or it shouldn't and uh on the other hand
exciting because i was
still learning a lot of new things it
was you know it's
when when something is so new i think
that um
starting out you know taking it step by
step can con
or at least it made sense in my mind so
so for me that was my way into property
just
and to do what you've done i mean
as you know i run a training academy
which is cost
thousands of pounds and we teach really
advanced strategies about raising
finance rents and rents and lease
options
you didn't really want to do all that
stuff you're saying actually i'm an
investor and i just want to i just want
to buy
at a good price i want to rent out i
want to get a good return
so you've literally managed to do this
just from going on the crash course to
be fair you've been on multiple times
yes but but but you've been on you've
been on the crash course and
the crash course how much did you pay to
go on the property investors crash
course
uh i think one pound one pound yeah
so was was it a good investment it was a
great investment i would say
yeah uh with an unquantifiable roi
uh absolutely amazing uh as i said to
you earlier i think
the the most interesting thing about the
crash course is not
um it's not just the knowledge which is
massively important
but also the the mindset i mean i
remember the exercises
and i like your approach um i think that
people that love property consume
a lot of content about property um not
necessarily just yours
the difference between your content and
other people's i found
is that there's a lot of differences one
i mentioned about the fine details that
you go
into the second thing i for example
remember this exercise i don't know if
you still do it or if it's changed it's
improved
but i remember this exercise where you
would stand in front of
two 3 000 people with a white um
a blank uh white board saying
okay guys so what's your biggest fear
and then people would just
think about i don't know no tenant what
if you have no what if you haven't got a
tenant you buy a house
and then the house is actually costing
you money because you're not making
anything
um and everyone's biggest fears
started to to um to to be to be voiced
and and you would
you would just write them down one after
the other and then you would come up
with your own because obviously
uh people that aren't in the industry
aren't necessarily scared
uh about what should scare them the most
but they're scared about different
things so you would say what about a bad
tenant
would wouldn't that be worse oh yeah
that would be worse
and and instead of um so instead of
shaming people that are scared of
investing in property you would actually
address
each and every one of the of the fears
that people normally have
and what happens well i don't know what
happens to most people but to me
that just that was a liberating moment
that's
great because it's really important to
to do that that's called risk assessing
you know and and well some people might
say well i haven't got any fears i'm
just going to be a courageous investor
well
you should because things can go wrong
and as you said
we with the crash course we go through
all the different things bad tenant no
tenant bad house all the different
problems you could have
and then and then i go through each
point and say right how can we
of prevent this from happening and of
course there's a possibility things will
go wrong
there always is because otherwise it
wouldn't be an investment it would be a
guarantee
and by very nature of investing there's
risk associated to it like any
investment
but we want to invest as safely as
possible and make sure that we're
actually
going to eliminate the risks as best we
can which is great and
hopefully you've applied that into your
10 houses absolutely and not just the
houses that's the reason why i like uh
i like the uh crash course so much
because if you have no intention of
getting into property
and you went to one of your crash
courses i think you will get
so much value out of it just mindset
business in general
then of course if you're interested in
property then that you know you should
be
you should go but even if you weren't uh
there's so much value that you can get
the risk analysis risk assessment isn't
necessarily
um natural to everyone it wasn't for me
yeah it isn't so it's something that i
had to think about it's something that i
had to learn
and uh i'm glad i did and of course you
can apply to property we can apply to
anything in life yeah
and you've said that you've applied a
lot of stuff to your current business
how how is your business going at the
moment is it is it thriving is it
surviving
is it it's great it's great because uh
the uh
i think the software industry has been
the probably one of the least
affected by the pandemic and and
the madness so uh yeah
it's going well and the property side um
i've heard
horror stories uh from the industrial
and commercial
uh real estate but personally it's been
it's been great
and and to have ten houses and have a
business that's doing really i mean what
sort of
what sort of turnover does your business
have uh we
uh six six figures uh so yeah just about
and you look kind of pretty young so how
how how old yeah i'm i'm 29
i'm 29 yeah same age yeah right that's
awesome i'm a bit older i think i mean
november of your 30s
okay cool this is a few months older
than me um what about
the other properties then so i know you
say you got the first
five in the uk on trends
yes and they're all similar sort of
problems very similar
yeah so kind of you know this works okay
i like this i get paid every month let's
just do it again
why did you then decide to take that
system and then go and adapt it and do
it in it
like again the things that i learned
about mindset from from
from the crash course or or the videos
or your um
your one of the messages that i think
um stand out in in what you say is
uh whenever there is a problem there is
opportunity
if there were no if you know if we had
no problems then there wouldn't be a
need for
starting a new business because what
problem are you trying to solve there
are no problems
so obviously you can't take this to an
extreme but
um you said in one of your crash courses
i remember there were people coming
from australia coming from india coming
from canada i remember a guy coming from
canada
and um you said everything i teach
i teach from a uk's point of view
because
you're from the uk you live in the uk
you invest in the uk you know about the
law and regulations in the uk
but that doesn't mean that it can't be
applied elsewhere you're just not sure
to what extent and um and in my
in my head i was thinking well i have
this great connection
uh to to italy being italian having
my family and a lot of my friends back
in italy
um you know not even two hours away
what about taking a look over there and
seeing if this
particular technique of the buy to let
of of buy low rent high
of everything i've learned from from
your content your books
can be applied also in italy and i took
a look
and because of the um the current
situation
house prices and and the demand uh
to me it just made sense so at that
point i was a little bit more confident
because the money was coming in from
property
and uh so i decided to take a risk
and and uh buy my first property in
italy uh and uh
and then i just repeat it because i like
the
i like the results yeah you saw that it
worked i think that when you say to
people
be careful obviously from from i
understand you
as a as a coach um you have to
manage expectations so you tell people
this works well in the uk
i'm not sure if it's going to work as
well in your home country
but that means that it can work less
well
or more well yeah right it can work
better
and uh you know the the yields are
pretty good in
in my hometown so we found in italy that
it's working
better than in stoke on trent yeah i
think it's too soon to say because i've
only been investing in italy for uh less
than a year we started the srl
the um ltd in italy again nobody's doing
it
no nobody's doing it so you're you're
most of uh what you teach your
techniques
i don't think many people are doing that
and it's an experiment
so i may come back in two three years
saying oh actually the yields are not
that
that much better but for now it's it's
exciting and i'm learning so much how
much
then i mean in in italy whereabouts are
you investing uh geneva
it's uh it's um on the other side of
venice by the sea close to france
beautiful okay it's a beautiful place so
how how much
are you buying houses four minutes today
uh so
one deal we did um i think we paid
27 000 for this uh those pounds now
we're talking still sorry 20
27 000 euros which is quite similar to
pounds yeah it's like 25
000 okay more or less so you bought it
for about 25 grand presumably you just
bought it
cash uh yes so you didn't get a mortgage
i didn't get them
that's what you do here now in the uk
you're getting mortgages exactly and
this is one thing with the with italy
that it's uh well
i'll come to that yeah but um yeah 25
000 and you
you rent uh you rent them out for around
400.
so it's uh that's very interesting it's
very interesting yeah so you buying it
for like 25 000
pounds and then you're renting out for
like 400 that that
that's a ridiculously high yield and
we're just getting started because i'm
only looking at the open market
i don't know what i'm doing meaning i
don't have great experience doing it i
haven't been doing it for years
and the banks in italy you see the
mortgage companies in the uk you you
send your application
they look at your data they look at your
uh your financials and then they make a
decision
it's fairly straightforward in italy it
is an asteroid forward meaning that the
banks
have to it's only the banks by the way
that lend you money for a house or
mainly banks
and you have to have a relationship with
them it's not that you just
suddenly turn up on their website and
you make an application and call them
um it's um it's mainly through
relationships that that you acquire
uh trust and then money so i had to open
an account with the bank that's
established in the city um
and then and you know this is what i'm
looking forward to next year
getting into partnership with banks that
um and
using and leveraging other people's
money because so far it's been a kind of
a sole venture in italy
that sounds i'm getting pretty excited
if i'm perfectly honest yeah so
in terms of capital appreciation what's
the expected appreciation in those areas
i mean obviously you can't know for sure
but what's the expectation or do you
have any ideas
i don't have any ideas but the prices
have gone down
so much that frankly i cannot i cannot
make sense of
of uh of any further depreciation so
um so the thing is it's the same story i
teach about
in the uk how to predict prices but it's
the same in italy because
you know what i teach at the crash
course where i was like when houses go
down then they're only going to go up
and if houses have gone up then they're
going to go down that's that that is a
worldwide
economic pattern and trait so you've
kind of taken that into italy and said
well houses have buttoned out
you can buy them for like 25 grand the
yield and the returns
really really good the expected capital
appreciation is probably good
because i bet you won't have to build a
house for less than that probably
yeah so exciting times absolutely and
you know when i bought my first one
people
and and with that with the with the
through a company so
people were dismayed i remember the the
italian account like are you sure you're
doing this
yeah i'm really sure i'm doing this why
are they shocked
because there isn't as far as i can tell
i don't know i lived in italy for 18
years but i
i don't know as far as i can tell
people don't uh don't seem to understand
that
there is no concept of a professional
landlord as far as i can tell maybe
there is but
um i haven't seen one and all the people
that are landlords they happen to be
landlords
and they have all their all their
properties um
personally uh maybe maybe a couple of
them they don't have a company
so they don't have companies and they
don't take it as a as a as a business
they take it as a oh yeah i you know i
do this on the side from
it's it's not as um do you reckon i
could take a crash course to italy would
that go down well
i don't know you should try well they
speak english don't they mostly
yeah especially in the north where most
people study english at school be my
translator or something i would love to
yeah
but maybe we can take it to italy and
you've got five houses now in italy are
you planning on expanding that and
growing them more 100
yeah and uh i'm not sure again watching
your videos
i can i can skip so many steps right i
remember watching one of your videos
where you were saying
um you know i had this in my mind of
getting more and more flat more and more
houses more and more properties
uh but i realized
through mentorship that
it would be better for me to focus on
bigger deals
so i'm also kind of thinking along the
same lines
thinking okay so what am i going to do
am i going to carry on with these
small flats all scattered around the
city or am i going to do something
something different and i think that
next year is going to be
i'm going to do next year is going to be
very exciting because i'm going to be
able to do what i've always wanted to do
which is
leverage other people's money and do
bigger projects
for now i'm doing all the all the stuff
that i wouldn't want to be doing which
is
gaining trust with banks getting into
conversation with banks getting a lot of
rejections
um getting acquainted with with the
system how it works all the bureaucracy
so we've we've had to do a lot of a lot
of things that
um you know people wouldn't wouldn't
want to do necessarily
but next year it's going to be so
exciting and you know for these reasons
i think definitely if you can start
doing bigger deals maybe even in italy
big deals in italy using other people's
money yeah i know you've been
using your own money combined with the
bank's manner here in the uk
but yeah i'm excited to see you scale
this
what's been the biggest hard ship in
especially with the whole thing in italy
what's been the hot biggest obstacle
that you've had to overcome i think the
biggest
obstacle is uh other people's
uh mindset it's it's always you have to
have some confidence
in in the uk i had lots of help because
uh
systems um are are in place
for you to to do these kinds of these
kinds of deals
for example acquiring um getting a
mortgage uh i could uh
i had access to your content um
i found a lot of like-minded people here
in london especially
i'm very lucky to to to be here and um
in italy you don't have that necessarily
i didn't i didn't find that
so um again looking for an accountant
that had experience with uh with a
limited company
doing what we're doing which is buy to
let
i mean good luck so you're gonna have to
go through this um uh this
there's gonna be a little bit more
friction everything has to be
uh has to come from you there won't be
any other input from the outside world
that will
completely unsaturated market i think so
that's the way i'm looking at it
that's the way uh i feel about it yeah
and what advice would you give to
someone that was maybe in
canada australia or wherever and they're
watching my content they're watching my
videos they've done
my online training or they've flown in
to come to a crash course like many
people do
and they they're considering should they
invest in the uk or should they use the
strategies and invest in their home
country
what what should what kind of things
should they be looking for and what
would you say to them
so i would say to them that the most
important
the easiest thing to do is to focus on
what you don't have
so looking at your content uh people are
gonna focus on the one thing
that you mentioned that they may not get
access to for example
and i think that's very natural and it
happened to me as well
they should rather focus on they should
try and focus on what they have that you
don't have
so there's something in canada or
any other country that that's possible
that here may be impossible
yeah so starting from that and if they
really
run out of options and they find that in
their home country for whatever reason
there isn't much opportunity in property
then they may consider
um looking at other countries countries
where
they they feel they have what they need
and the uk is a prime example the thing
is with property though i so agree with
you is because
properties are pretty i mean yes there
are some countries that have ludicrous
laws where you can't own a house
or whatever but generally speaking it's
quite a simple concept
if you own land no one can take that
away from you
and if you build a house everyone needs
to live in a home and people are always
going to pay what's what they need
and what brings value to them so the
idea of having a building house or
buying a house
owning land renting it out it's a very
universal global thing that can happen
and i think that's why so many people
from other countries have been reaching
out to me saying hey i've been watching
your videos and i've done the same thing
in canada or australia
and for me it's a really exciting
feeling and it kind of opens me up to be
able to teach more people which is which
is also great
um but as you say people sometimes will
say oh i can't do that though
or oh lease option agreements aren't
allowed well then don't do a lease
option agreement then do something
different or they'll say
oh we don't have right move we'll find
an equivalent or
go and walk into an estate agent's
office
don't find a problem you've got to find
a solution which is what
you've talked about throughout this
whole interview yeah um
yeah yeah 100 i think i think it's uh
it's not as easy as
finding the problem and finding the
problem is always the easiest thing so
uh finding the problem is okay but then
again just you know
look further i think i think there's a
lot of space in there yeah in
in the um in the real estate industry
which is one of the oldest
industries in yeah absolutely well i'm
really really really excited
glad to see killing it on on the
business side as well as the investment
size
and uh folks if you want to follow his
journey um
let me know let me know if you want me
to get him back on on youtube as a part
two in six twelve months time
also if you're from another country if
you're interested in seeing students
from another country whether it be
hong kong canada australia different
parts of europe
let me know let me know where you're
from let me know where you want to see
more students and i'll bring people on
i'll interview them
thanks so much for watching the channel
i think you'll agree claudio is an
absolute boss i'll leave a link with his
details in the description if you want
to get in touch if you're in italy maybe
and also please don't forget to smash
the like button subscribe to the channel
and turn the notification bell on so you
don't miss a future video
if you want to see more interviews with
winners wednesday success students you
can see them right here
and you can subscribe right here i look
forward to seeing you
next time